ça on a la peine capitale dans le cadre
des manifestations déclenchées par la
mort de Marsa Amini la répression s'abat
aveugle violente sanglante depuis le
début de la contestation plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont été arrêtées
plusieurs centaines sont mortes 400
viennent d'être condamnés à des peines
pouvant aller jusqu'à 10 ans de prison
les CI de du régime veulent écraser un
mouvement populaire où les femmes sont
en première ligne ou l'émancipation et
le but femme vie liberté ce slogan est
porteur des espoirs d'un peuple nous
devons être à la hauteur de cet espoir
le 10 novembre dernier ma collègue
m'arrêter vous interpellé pour demander
que la France exige l'exclusion de
l'Iran de la Commission de la condition
de la femme à l'ONU malgré le retard je
suis heureux que votre gouvernement ait
fini par écouter cette juste
revendication cette exclusion est
actuellement en débat à New York
certes des sanctions étaient prises par
l'Union européenne certes les
condamnations internationales existent
mais sont-elles suffisantes devant
l'ampleur de la répression mes chers
collègues un baril de pétrole vaut-il
plus que le sang d'un manifestant aussi
ma question est simple alors que le
peuple iranien se bat pour les droits
humains comment la France peut-elle
l'aider comment la France peut-elle agir
au sein de l'Union européenne pour que
la répression cesse et que la jeunesse
iranienne est prise de liberté
remportent son combat de lumière contre
l'obscurantisme
[Musique]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre madame borne
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Patrick
femme vit liberté ce slogan est né en
Iran mais il a très vite dépassé les
frontières ces trois mots sont des
symboles puissants et un appel à la
liberté
en Iran le régime déni leurs droits aux
femmes il est cible pour ce qu'elles
sont
l'oppression que subissent les femmes ne
date pas de la mort tragique de Massa à
mini elle s'incarne dans les lois du
pays port du voile obligatoire mariage
précoce dès la puberté interdiction de
l'avortement crime d'honneur en Iran
devant les tribunaux la parole la parole
d'une femme vaut la moitié de celle d'un
homme
contre la négation de ces droits humains
un mouvement de protestation est né qui
ne faiblit pas qui s'est étendu à toute
une partie de la jeunesse et se poursuit
depuis maintenant deux mois il se
poursuit malgré la répression violente
qui a fait plus de 500 morts dont des
dizaines d'enfants au moins 15000
personnes ont été arrêtées deux Iraniens
ont déjà été condamnés à mort et
exécutés à la suite de leur
participation aux manifestations il se
poursuit malgré l'emprisonnement de
journalistes toujours plus nombreux le
président de la République a eu
l'occasion de dire notre admiration
notre respect et notre soutien à celles
et ceux qui défendent les droits
fondamentaux en Iran qu'il ne soit
permis au nom du gouvernement de leur
rendre hommage de leur dire que nous
sommes avec eux
face à la gravité de la situation la
France n'est pas impassible nous
agissons monsieur le Président canard de
manière forte ferme et résolu avec nos
partenaires européens nous avons envoyé
lundi pour la quatrième fois un signal
puissant d'unité et de fermeté aux
autorités iraniennes nous avons encore
élargi la liste des personnes et
entitées faisant l'objet de mesures
restrictives en y ajoutant 20 membres du
régime ainsi que la radio télévision
iranienne irrigue nous prenons des
sanctions significatives gel désavoir
interdiction de pénétrer sur le
territoire de l'Union et interdiction de
mettre des fonds ou des ressources
économiques à la disposition des
personnes et entités concernées
notre ligne est claire nous mettrons
tout en oeuvre pour que le régime le
régime iranien sorte de sa logique de
répression nous avons ainsi adopté il y
a deux jours de nouvelles conclusions du
Conseil de l'Union européenne sur l'Iran
qui établissent un cadre d'action
européen d'une grande fermeté enfin nous
soutenons les aspirations démocratiques
du peuple iranien la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colona a remis à remise samedi
avec son homologue allemandes le prix
franco-allemande des droits de l'homme à
Massa Amini et aux femmes iraniennes ces
efforts nous les poursuivrons sans nous
laisser intimider le régime cible nous
ressortissants certains sont détenus
dans des conditions inacceptables nous
continuons à exiger leur libération ce
qui se trouve en Iran ou envisage de s'y
rendre s'exposent à des risques de
détention arbitraire je veux donc ici
renouveler mon appel à la plus grande
vigilance monsieur le Président kaner je
redis la France est restera aux côtés de
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
combattent pour la liberté pour les
droits humains je vous remercie
monsieur le Président Kader
chez le Président Madame ministre nous
avons ici au Sénat soutenu l'Arménie
nous avons ici au Sénat soutenu
l'Ukraine nous voulons aussi soutenir le
peuple iranien dans son combat pour la
liberté j'aimerais qu'un jour ce peuple
puisse faire sien ce beau poème de 1942
de Paul Eluard liberté j'écris ton nom
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Eric gold pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre malgré des efforts notables
pour le déploiement de la fibre il ne se
passe pas une semaine sans que les élus
locaux soient sollicités pour des
dysfonctionnements chantier technique
abandonné coupure fréquente liée au
réseau aérien travail bâclé sur les
raccordements
refus d'installer le cuivre dans une
construction neuve qui de bénéficie pas
encore de la fibre abonnement prélevé
sans que l'habitation soit raccordée
déception par rapport au débit les
motifs de se mécontentement général sont
innombrables
l'ARCEP vient d'ailleurs de publier les
résultats d'une analyse de terrain qui
confirme la situation avec des défauts
notamment sur l'état des câblages et ce
que certains appellent des raccordements
en plein de nouilles constat partagé par
lavica présidé par notre collègue
Patrick chaise qui dénonce des
opérateurs faisant trop souvent appel
aux sous-traitants sans vérifier la
qualité ni la pérennité des
installations
15 à 20% des abonnés serait ainsi
touchés par un dysfonctionnement
monsieur le ministre nous sommes encore
loin du 100% comme annoncé du territoire
couvert par la fibre en 2022 et les
chiffres du déploiement cachent
d'importants disparités territoriale
entraînant pour certaines ou pour
certains plutôt une double peine
en effet en parallèle de ce déploiement
souvent insatisfaisante le réseau cuivre
est progressivement abandonné et donc
mal entretenu y compris dans les
territoires qui n'ont toujours pas la
fibre et qui subissent des délais de
dépannage atteignant plusieurs mois des
territoires qui étaient déjà fragiles et
qui se trouvent davantage pénalisé par
cette situation avec des conséquences
potentiellement critiques je pense par
exemple à la téléassistance qui ne peut
fonctionner qu'avec un réseau efficient
monsieur le ministre j'aimerais donc
savoir comment l'État entend agir
vis-à-vis des opérateurs qui n'ont pas
tenu leurs engagements s'il est prévu de
mieux informer les élus comme une par
commune et de remettre à niveau le
service juste après vente du réseau
cuivre qui continue de jouer un rôle
essentiel dans certains territoires je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole des communistes délégués en
charge la transition numérique des
télécommunications Jean-Noël Barrault
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gold je partage évidemment
votre constat qu'on concernant les
défauts de qualité dans le déploiement
de la fibre qui place nos concitoyens
parfois dans des situations intenables
elles sont le fruit de plusieurs
facteurs d'abord la rapidité du
déploiement de la ville dans notre pays
en disant la France est devenue le pays
le plus avancé en matière de fibres avec
77% des locaux raccordables deuxièmement
à l'existence de réseau de fibres
historiquement mal dimensionnés
notamment ceux qui ont été déployés
parmi les premiers il y a 10 ans enfin
au recours vous laïcité un nombre trop
important de niveau de sous-traitance
même si cette pratique a largement
diminuée face à l'accroissement des
difficultés qui remontent de toutes
parts et en particulier de la part des
élus le gouvernement et l'ARCEP ont
saisi la filière Télécom afin qu'elle
formule des engagements ces engagements
ont été pris fin septembre et il
s'articule autour de trois axes premier
élément le renforcement de la qualité
des interventions avec une certification
des compétences minimales requises pour
les raccordements finaux
deuxièmement la transmission par les
opérateurs commerciaux de leur planning
d'intervention et le partage des
comptes-rendus d'intervention de manière
à ce que les les pannes éventuels
puissent être secouru plus rapidement
enfin le troisième axe et la reprise des
infrastructures dégradées que ce soit au
niveau des points de mutualisation ou
des réseaux vieillissants ou mal
dimensionnés plusieurs opérateurs ont
déjà notifié leur plan de reprise de
1000 points de mutilation correspondant
à 450 000 locaux ce plan le gouvernement
veille à sa mise en œuvre le contrôle en
est en revient à larcep et des points de
suivi réguliers sont effectués en
présence des associations d'élus pour
autant le déploiement de la fibre et le
projet d'arrêt de commercialisation du
ne doivent pas se traduire par une
baisse de qualité de service ou une
exclusion de certains de nos concitoyens
la qualité du réseau cuivre doit être
maintenue en attendant sa fermeture
technique l'État ne transigera pas et
sur ce point notre message est clair pas
de dépose du cuivre tant qu'une solution
fibre n'est pas proposée aux usagers
sachez monsieur le sénateur que je
veille personnellement à ce que cette
transition s'accompagne par ailleurs des
garanties nécessaires de disponibilité
de qualité et d'abord d'habilité de
service pour tous nos concitoyens merci
monsieur le ministre je vais maintenant
donner la parole à notre collègue Paul
Toussain Parisi pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires elle
porte sur un écosside annoncé que l'État
ne peut ignorer par l'ampleur de la
menace qu'il fait peser sur notre région
je parle du projet du Centre
d'enfouissement de yucadio aux abords du
deuxième plus grand fleuve de Corse le
tavignac à nous classer zone Natura 2000
et zone naturelle d'intérêt écologique
phonistique et fleuristique ce projet
fou c'est le stockage et l'enfouissement
de 120000 tonnes de Terra miantifères et
de 70 000 tonnes de déchets ménagés par
an sur 30 années un affouillement des
sols abyssal dans une zone géologique
instable les pieds dans l'eau ou
d'importants glissement de terrain ont
déjà été observés espèrent géologue
hydrobiologiste confirme et signe le
risque majeur de destruction de cette
écosystème aux conséquences dramat sur
la santé humaine et les générations à
venir je rappellerai ici que le tavigna
nous irrigue toute la plaine orientale
ou une agriculture diversifiée de
qualité labellisée est connu
mondialement pour sa production
d'agrumes est un inestimable réservoir
de biodiversité au cœur même duquel INRA
et sirad abri d'un précieux
conservatoire génétique des agrumes
d'Europe et d'ailleurs
mettre en péril l'alimentation en eau
potable toute une région détruire le
cœur agricole de la Corse hypothéquer la
santé humaine des générations futures
voilà Monsieur le Ministre les enjeux
dont il est question un acte criminel en
devenir dans la scène se joue
aujourd'hui sous nos yeux depuis six ans
nous demandons une interdiction totale
de ce projet malgré un arrêté de refus
initial pris par le préfet à l'intérieur
en 2016 et les prescriptions du préfet
François ravier en 2019 pour minimiser
les risques du projet
le combat juridique continue alors ma
question est simple saurez-vous au nom
du devoir supérieur de l'État à protéger
la vie et son écosystème être à nos
côtés pour interdire la logique
mercantile qui hypothèque notre
territoire est sacrifie la terre que
demain nous l'aiderons à nos enfants je
vous remercie pour vos réponses de la
transition écologique la cohésion des
territoires sur Christophe Béchu vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président on aime les
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateur je voudrais vous
remercier pour votre question vous
pointez du doigt et vous braquez les
projecteurs sur la situation très
complexe depuis 2015 de la Corse en
matière de gestion de déchets un tiers
des déchets qui sont produits sur l'île
sont triés orientés vers le continent
les deux tiers se voient 160 000 tonnes
doit être traité localement or les deux
installations de stockage qui existent
ne peuvent permettre dans l'accueillir
que 100000 tonnes par an face à ça une
société oriente Environnement a demandé
en 2016 à pouvoir stocker le long du
fleuve d'avenir à nous sur un site qui
potentiellement présente des risques
d'affaissement un site de stockage le
préfet a donc refusé sauf que le
tribunal administratif a cassé ce refus
en 2020 le préfet a donc pris une
décision qui a consisté à limiter avec
la vie d'ineris à un stockage partiel et
en novembre 2022 le tribunal
administratif a exigé que nous donnions
une autorisation complète de stockage
ce sujet est évidemment problématique il
y a l'autorité de la chose jugée et il y
a ce que vous décrivez en terme de
risque pointé y compris par les
autorités préfectorales plus largement
c'est la question de la gestion des
déchets en Corse qui se pose j'aurais dû
il y a quelques jours accompagné le mini
Gérald Darmanin à l'occasion d'un
déplacement encore pour les rencontrer
les élus puisque ce sujet fait partie de
l'agenda des discussions que nous avons
avec les élus insulaires c'est reporter
aux premières semaines de l'année 2023
je ne fierai pas mes responsabilités
j'irai la rencontre des élus je soutiens
évidemment la position du préfet je
soutiens les inquiétudes qui sont
exprimées par les élus locaux je
soutiens les risques qui ont été pointés
par beaucoup d'acteurs il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver une solution compte
tenu de la décision du tribunal
administratif et des risques que vous
pointez nous allons nous y atteler dans
les prochaines semaines
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Daniel Chassin pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le coût de l'énergie est
multiplié par 4 ou 5 c'est la teneur des
courriers que nous continuons à en
recevoir tous dans les entreprises en
détresse sur des territoires certes il y
a eu des évolutions sur le dispositif de
soutien de l'État aux entreprises mais
cela ne paraît pas suffisant pour un
bonhomme dentelle au dessus de 10
salariés nous créons des fermetures dans
le futur la solution réside dans
l'augmentation de notre production
d'énergie et diversification nos sources
énergétiques nous venons d'examiner un
projet de loi afin d'accélérer le
déploiement de CNR des ENR pour une
filière nucléaire d'avenir on devrait se
prononcer sur une nouvelle programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie
le 16
le 16 novembre dernier madame la
Première ministre a évoqué un travail
prochain dont l'objectif sera je cite de
relancer rapidement les investissements
dans les barrages sans nécessiter une
remise en concurrence qu'en est-il dans
de nombreux territoires notamment en
Corrèze nous avons un projet de station
de transfert d'énergie par pompage step
avec un pompage en heures creuse dans la
Dordogne rodena ce projet de stockage
malheureusement stagne depuis des
décennies il permettrait de répondre au
pic de consommation turbinant à la
demande et d'éviter de manquer
d'électricité et de réduire les coûts
mais voilà EDF n'est pas en position
d'investir dans ce projet en grande
partie à cause de l'ouverture à la
concurrence des concessions
hydroélectriques imposées par l'Europe
pourtant ce ministre l'énergie doit être
plus que jamais une question de
souveraineté pour notre pays monsieur le
ministre
ces dossiers qu'en est-il des
discussions engagées avec Bruxelles à
quoi pouvons-nous nous attendre
concernant les demandes de prorogation
des concessions merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique la cohésion des
territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Chassain
vous avez bien posé les termes du débat
l'hydroélectricité la première source
d'énergie renouvelable dans ce pays avec
26 gigawatts et nous pouvons nous
féliciter des investissements qui ont
été réalisés par nos grands anciens dans
ce domaine mais vous avez raison aussi
il y a à la fois une volonté
gouvernementale rappelée exprimée par la
première ministre et une situation qui
est complexe contenue de ces
perspectives d'ouverture à la
concurrence et plus encore du
précontentieux qui a été engagé par
l'Union européenne sur l'absence de mise
en concurrence pour le renouvellement
des concessions d'hydroélectricité la
volonté du gouvernement de faire en
sorte de favoriser des énergies
renouvelables et de nous appuyer sur
celles qui ont fait leur preuve comme
l’hydro-électricité est totale je veux
saluer le Sénat qui en votant l'article
16 coinquises de la loi d'accélération
sur les énergies renouvelables a
notamment valider un processus qui
devrait nous permettre de contourner
cette difficulté puisque cet article
prévoit que les dispositions sur les
investissements pour assurer la
pérennité d'un ouvrage hydroélectrique
puisse être réalisé sans mise en
concurrence c'est le chemin que suivre
j’ajoute que vous avez cité aussi celui
dont nous avons besoin EDF la nomination
d'un nouveau président directeur général
la discussion de sa feuille de route la
caractérisation d'une stratégie qui est
à la fois celle du gouvernement et celle
de l'entreprise avec la perspective de
la nationalisation nous permet d'avoir
un alignement d'astre pour pouvoir
relancer ce sujet la route est semée
d'embûches mais l'enjeu de la
souveraineté de retrouver la maîtrise de
notre énergie commande que nous
trouvions des solutions je sais votre
attachement à ce sujet vous l'avez
évoqué avec moi dès le tout début du
mois de juillet lors de notre première
rencontre je peux vous assurer que notre
détermination est totale pour dépasser
ses obstacles précontentieux et relancer
ce dont nous avons besoin une production
française d'énergie renouvelable qui
nous permettent de tenir le choc et
d'offrir à nos entreprises et à nos
ménages des tarifs qui soient
compétitifs
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Patrick chaise pour le groupe
les républicains
monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
la crise énergétique nous amène à revoir
nos organisations domestiques comme
professionnel afin d'adapter nos
consommations aux ressources disponibles
vous nous annoncez cependant depuis
quelques jours des phases de délestage
de réseau ces coupures locales limitées
dans le temps impacteront l'ensemble des
usagers ménages entreprises services
publics les réseaux de communication
électroniques qui ont pourtant prouvé
leur caractère indispensable durant les
phases de confinement seront également
touchés
je souhaite donc attirer l'attention du
Gouvernement sur le cas spécifique des
réseaux de téléphonie mobile qui a
chemine notamment les appels d'urgence
en effet en cas de coupure même
momentanée les numéros d'urgence y
compris le 112 ne seront pas accessibles
sur des ports entiers de nos territoires
je pense notamment au secteur moins
dense qui se sont des services que par
un seul pilone tout défaut
d'alimentation électrique entraînent
alors une impossibilité d'accéder au
Service les antennes n'étant pas
considérées comme des équipements
prioritaires de surcroît les éléments
les plus structurants du réseau
pourraient être aussi concernés la
coupure de certaines antennes aura des
répercussions sur le réseau national les
opérateurs pourraient être par exemple
dans l'incapacité d'assurer des missions
de sécurité intérieure
c'est pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est double quelle garantie
pouvez-vous nous donner sur la
cheminement des numéros d'urgence vers
les centres de régulation en tout temps
et en tout point du territoire
envisagez-vous de donner un statut de
réseau essentiel au réseau de
communication je vous remercie
pour vos réponses la parole est
communiste déléguer de la transition
numérique des télécommunications
monsieur Barrault monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur chaise
permettez-moi monsieur le sénateur de
saluer d'abord l'immense travail des
salariés d'EDF qui mettent notre pays
sur la bonne voie ainsi que l'esprit de
responsabilité des français puisque RTE
nous annonce une diminution de presque
10% de la consommation électrique la
semaine dernière par rapport aux années
précédentes dans notre pays la
continuité des appels d'urgence que vous
évoquez repose sur le 112 qui a
l'avantage d'être mutualisé entre tous
les opérateurs nous ouvrons depuis cet
été à limiter au maximum les
conséquences d'éventuelles délaissage
sur les réseaux de télécommunication et
donc sur ces appels d'urgence il s'agit
d'un travail inédit titanesque du fait
de la nature et des choix historiques
d'organisation des réseaux en France il
suppose de déterminer l'impact croisé
des 60 point d'alimentation du réseau
électrique avec les 110 000 équipement
télécoms dont 80 000 antennes et 30000
équipement structurants qui leur
permettent de communiquer entre elles je
rappelle par ailleurs que même en
l'absence de l'elystage les réseaux
télécom n'est pas infaillible et que
chaque antenne dans notre pays tombe en
panne pour raison technique ou en cas
d'intempéries en moyenne une fois par an
à la demande du gouvernement les
opérateurs ont ainsi déjà pris des
mesures importantes ils ont renforcé des
cet automne l'alimentation de plus de
1000 nœuds et coeurs de réseaux en les
équipant de batterie supplémentaires je
veille à ce que ces batteries soient
testées désormais chaque mois ils ont
considérablement réduit par ailleurs les
délais de transmission de la carte de
couverture du 112 afin que le ministère
de l'Intérieur puisse déployer des
moyens de secours additionnels en cas de
besoin en complément je vais vous dire
qu'en cas de délestage nous demanderons
aux opérateurs de réquisitionner tous
les équipements mobiles disponibles
ainsi que les équipes d'astreintes afin
de renforcer la résilience du 112 nous
veillerons également à ce que tous les
opérateurs effectuer des simulations
pour prioriser les antennes à préserver
pour renforcer la résilience du 112 sur
la balle du travail réalisé cet automne
par les préfets et enedis vous le voyez
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour garantir
l'accès au numéro d'urgence des Français
en cas de les stages mais aussi pour
garantir la résilience du réseau télécom
ces prochaines années
monsieur chaise
j'entends votre réponse monsieur le
ministre je nie pas vos échanges avec
les opérateurs mais reconnaissez qui
sont un peu tardif d'autant que je suis
pas persuadé que le délestage soit
vraiment la solution plutôt que des
mesures punitives je pense que des
actions récompenses sur des tarifs par
exemple pourrait être plus vertueuse les
territoires ruraux vont être pénalisés
attention donc à ce que les zones
délestées ne soient pas une fois de plus
les zones délaissées
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe de l'unionfanterie
le Parlement européen à la demande du
groupe Renaissance et donc de votre
gouvernement a obtenu le vote d'un
amendement qui fait état de sa
préoccupation au vu des subventions
versées aux associations liées aux
Frères musulmans qui pourraient être
mieux contrôlés ça pourrait être une
bonne nouvelle mais pourquoi
proposez-vous à Strasbourg ce que vous
refusez ici en effet avec notre groupe
nous dénonçons depuis longtemps ces
anomalies et je dois dire que le mot est
assez faible et notamment lors d'une
question d'actualité sur le même sujet
au gouvernement le 25 novembre 2021 sans
aucun résultat plus récemment le
gouvernement a retoqué plusieurs
amendements au PLF pour la troisième
année consécutive visant à contrôler les
financements des associations nous
parlons d'à peu près de millions d'euros
quand allez-vous être plus vigilant sur
ces financements il ne suffit pas de
s'indigner de la campagne du Conseil de
l'Europe pour la diversité en Europe
faisant figurer une jeune fille voilée
il aurait fallu faire en sorte que cette
campagne ne soit pas lancée
sainte-agnation a été véritablement
efficace si on en juge la fiche de la
campagne de l'UNICEF que j'ai là la
journée de l'enfant avec une jeune fille
voilée voilà très efficace c'est très
intéressant
donc ce préoccuper s'indigner condamné
n'est pas suffisant quand allez-vous
assécher les financements des Frères
musulmans leur interdire tout
financement public et les inscrire sur
la liste des organisations terroristes
je vous remercie
pour vos réponses
la parole de Kev Adam Colona ministre de
l'Europe des Affaires étrangères
ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Goulet la
protection de l'institutions contre les
ingérences étrangères est nécessaire à
l'intégrité de nos démocraties cela
requiert en effet de la vigilance croyez
bien que le gouvernement est mobilisé et
actif pour que les institutions
européennes intègrent bien le risque de
telles ingérences quelle qu'elle soit je
dis bien quelle qu'elle soit et
défendent notre socle commun de valeur
avec Gérald Darmanin j'ai
personnellement et avec Laurence Boone à
mes côtés j'ai personnellement saisi à
ce sujet la Commission européenne et le
O représentant il y a plusieurs mois et
je l'ai fait à nouveau auprès de Joseph
Borel
mi-septembre c'est ma mémoire est bonne
nous continuerons donc madame la
sénatrice de pousser le sujet notamment
pour un suivi plus fin des activités des
associations financées par l'Union
européenne afin qu'aucune d'entre elles
ne peuvent sous influence des agendas à
rebours de nos objectifs d'intégration
d'émancipation citoyenne et d'égale
dignité entre les femmes et les hommes
l'inscription que vous proposez des
Frères musulmans sur la liste européenne
des organisations terroristes n'est pas
possible madame la sénatrice car cette
organisation ne répond à aucun des
critères fixés par les règles
européennes cela ne change rien
cependant à notre détermination à
préserver le bon fonctionnement de notre
démocratie française et européenne je
vous remercie
d'abord l'Autriche a inscrit les freins
musulmans sur la liste des organisations
terroristes les États-Unis ils pensent
je pense qu'il faut exiger des réponses
de la commission vous savez très bien
que les milliers et les millions d'euros
qui circulent sont véhiculés par le
Qatar qui lui protège les Frères
musulmans vous savez très bien qu'il
gangrène notre République ils espionnent
nos boîtes nourrissent des signes tongs
je crois vraiment qu'il faut en finir
avec cette naïveté et très franchement
exigé de la Commission européenne des
réponses et le minimum que nous
puissions demander
la parole est à notre collègue
Eric Bocquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste avait la
parole merci monsieur le Président et
Madame la première ministre messieurs et
mesdames les membres du gouvernement
chers collègues le 10 juillet 2018 lors
de l'examen du projet de loi liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel ici
même notre groupe était intervenu à
l'article premier en
compétences cette critique je cite d'un
compte personnel de formation abondé en
heure nous passons donc à un compte
abondé en euros
si le nombre d'heures prises en charge
par le compte personnel de formation
diminue il est à parier que les
formations les plus longues et les plus
coûteuses devront faire l'objet d'un
financement complémentaire reposant
essentiellement sur le salarié fin de
citation dimanche à l'Assemblée
nationale on a adopté un amendement au
projet de loi de finances pour 2023 qui
prévoit de contraindre les salariés à
prendre en charge de 20 à 30% du coût
des formations nous avions donc raison
d'alerter il y a quatre ans sur les
risques de faire peser sur les salariés
le prix des formations professionnelles
c'est d'autant plus injuste qu'elle est
justifiée uniquement essentiellement par
un souci d'économie budgétaire qui est
décidément l'alpha et l'oméga de vos
choix budgétaires monsieur le ministre
ma question est double la subvention de
l'apprentissage a coûté 4 milliards
d'euros à l'État se désengagement
organisé des entreprises au financement
de l'apprentissage vous amène à réduire
le droit à la formation de fait première
question allez-vous revenir sur ces
subventions indues qui opposent
formation professionnelle et continue et
salariés deuxième question allez pour
faire accroître le contrôle les
organismes de formation qui accumulent
une rente générée par les coûts
exorbitants des formations proposées au
détriment des salariés de notre pays
pour vous répondre la parole est un
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle madame Grandjean il
avait la parole merci monsieur le
président
le sénateur Boké j'ai écouté avec
attention ce que vous venez de dire à
l'intention du gouvernement et je crois
que c'est tout le contraire rendre le
système plus juste et plus efficace
combattre les fraudes régulariser les
dérives et toujours associé davantage la
formation un projet professionnel
d'avenir et notre ambition
je le rappelle le gouvernement a porté
ces derniers mois un certain nombre de
mesures pour améliorer la qualité de la
formation cela a conduit à éliminer
environ deux tiers des certifications
dans l'intérêt n'étaient pas avérée pour
l'évolution professionnelle de nos
concitoyens il a également conduit à
évincer des plateformes les organismes
de formation qui ne satisfaisaient pas
les exigences attendues par ailleurs
nous avons depuis octobre
débattus et adopté ensemble une loi
portez votre par votre collègue Martin
lévrier visant à lutter contre le
démarchage abusif et les fraudes il
s'agit à présent pour y parvenir de
faire en sorte que chaque bénéficiaire
s'engage de manière active dans sa
formation avec une participation
financière
mais nous voulons que ce soit juste
c'est pour cela que les demandeurs
d'emploi en seront dispensés tout comme
les salariés qui ont co-construit un
projet professionnel avec leur employeur
via un abonnement c'est sur ces bases
efficacité et équilibre que vont
s'ouvrir les concertations avec les
partenaires sociaux avec les
parlementaires avec les acteurs de la
formation pour déterminer le niveau de
cette participation et son plafonnement
convaincu que la formation est une clé
essentielle dans les parcours
professionnels cette responsabilité de
l'individu ne doit pas être un frein à
l'accès à la formation nous y serons
attentifs je vous remercie monsieur
Bocquet oui votre réponse n'est pas
rassurante en 2018 le directeur de kéné
de votre ancienne collègue Muriel
Pénicaud disait aux partenaires sociaux
qu'il n'y aurait pas de problème de
financement car les cotisations
patronales seraient augmentées en
conséquence s'il le fallait en tout cas
vous ne nous expliquer que avec ce choix
c'est la première fois dans notre
histoire sociale que nos concitoyens
vont devoir financer de même l'accès à
un droit qui
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue André
gatelin pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
monsieur le ministre l'ONG seve Guardi
fenders qui offre pour la défense des
droits humains à l'échelle
internationale vient de publier un
rapport mettant en évidence l'existence
de 110 postes illégaux de police chinois
répartis sur plus de 50 pays poste qui
viserait à contrôler réprimer voire à
extrader hors de tout cadre légal des
citoyens chinois vers leur pays
d'origine l'accusation est grave elle
est très grave mais le rapport en
question est étayé par de très nombreux
documents et témoignages sur ces
pratiques illégales opérées hors du
territoire chinois en France ce sont
pour l'instant quatre postes illégaux de
ce type qui ont été dénombrer à Paris
Noisy-le-Grand et Aubervilliers
surveillance des établissements
taïwanais oui tibétains pression exercée
sur des citoyens chinois réfugiés en
France contrôle politique de la diaspor
à Brest la liste des activités inities
dénoncées par l'ONG est longue interrogé
plusieurs responsables chinois ont
reconnu l'existence de ses postes en
arguant que ceux-ci se limiteraient à
des services d'assistance de type
consulaire auprès de leurs concitoyens
mais même sans autorisation de telles
activités sont de toute façon illégale
au regard du droit international au-delà
et si l'effet dénoncé par l'ONG sont
avérés ce serait sans conteste une
atteinte très grave à notre souveraineté
et même une forme toute nouvelle de
séparatisme opéré sur notre sol par des
agents illégaux d'une puissance
étrangère aujourd'hui tous les pays
européens concernés soit enquête à
l'exception de la Grèce et d'Halloween
Hongrie ont déjà officiellement
diligentés une enquête sur ces pratiques
inquiétantes alors Monsieur le Ministre
avez-vous ou entendez-vous diligenter
une enquête de ce type en France je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est ministre de l'intérieur des autres
Roberts que Gérald Darmanin monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
secteurs monsieur le sénateur je veux
dire ici qu'effectivement la France ne
peut accepter en aucun cas les attentats
ta souveraineté en temps lutter
extrêmement fortement contre les
influences étrangères sur son sol et
n'acceptera pas comme de pouvoir
accepter dans le passé dans le futur que
les règles internationales notamment qui
prévoit l'accueil de ces ressortissants
des pays se fassent au détriment de
notre bonne relation entre état qu'il
s'agisse de la Chine et de tout autre
état
la DGSI est en effet à l'écoute de
révélation qui ont été pu être mise en
place par cette organisation
gouvernementale elle a d'ailleurs
travaillé en amont bien évidemment de
ces révélations je lui ai demandé
d'accentuer évidemment son enquête de
renseignement auprès du Gouvernement de
la République et du président de la
République vous comprendrez que c'est
pas ici que je pourrais détailler ces
résultats mais si vous le permettez je
vous invite à vous rapprocher de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement qui elle est sous le saut
Confidentiel Défense pour que nous
donnions toutes les informations si le
président du parlement du projet où la
présentation nationale ou la délégation
elle-même le président buffet venait à
demander ces informations ce qui est
certain c'est que pour tous les pays
extrêmement agressifs dans la
contre-influence sur notre sol le
président de la République voit la plus
de 4 ans a demandé des moyens renforcés
à la DGSI l'occasion si vous souhaitez
dans le cadre de la délégation
renseignement de pouvoir les détailler
pour vous rassurer que la France
acceptera jamais ce genre de pratique
qui reste à confirmer pour ce qui
concerne les quatre postes qui ont été
évoqués par cette ONG en France
merci
la parole est à notre collègue corinaire
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait à madame la Première
ministre pour évoquer notre souveraineté
sanitaire car le sujet est à la fois
économique et sanitaire des pénuries de
médicaments et de dispositifs médicaux
cela fait des années que ça dure mais
aujourd'hui le niveau des manquants a
atteint des sommets séduit jamais vu
paracétamol et amoxicilline continuent
de faire l'actualité et le ministère
impose quant à lui des contingentements
mais aujourd'hui c'est aussi l'un des
acteurs mondiaux des industries de santé
le dernier fabricant français de poche
de perfusion pour les hôpitaux qui est
en redressement judiciaire et qui
cherche à repreneur et si aucun
repreneur n'est trouvé d'ici le 5
janvier alors l'entreprise risque de
fermer définitivement les hôpitaux
s'inquiète il n'est pas besoin de cela
comment demain pourront-ils
s'approvisionner en poche de perfusion
c'est un nouveau symbole de notre
indépendance sanitaire qui est en danger
comment expliquer vous cela Monsieur le
Ministre et que comptez-vous faire
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole communiste
de la santé de la prévention Monsieur
François Braun
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Center madame la sénatrice
Corinne Imbert
les causes liées à ces pénuries de
médicaments sont multiples déjà la crise
covid en vente une modification de
prescription plus 13% par exemple pour
le paracétamol il y a également des
soucis sur le principe actif et tout
l'intérêt de rapatrier ce principe actif
en Europe et en France dans le cadre du
Plan France 2030 par exemple également
des soucis de production ou de
distribution comme c'est récemment le
cas concernant le doliprane pédiatrique
qui est produit essentiellement en
Allemagne et avec un mouvement social
chez Sanofi qui heureusement a pris fin
récemment et qui va nous permettre de
retrouver nos stocks cette situation
vous le savez n'est pas propre à la
France elle concerne l'ensemble du
territoire européen voire plus en ce qui
concerne l'amoxicilline c'est une
pénurie au niveau national liée à un
défaut de production notre système de
surveillance qui est porté par l'Agence
nationale du système de sécurité pardon
du médicament nous permet chose nous
permet déjà d'être alerté très tôt
puisque les alertes arrivent lorsque nos
stocks diminuent en dessous de un mois
pour la plupart des produits donc ça
veut pas dire que nous n'en avons plus
mais en tout cas des stocks sont
extrêmement bas et elle nous permet
aussi d'identifier les causes ces causes
nous permettant d'avoir des actions
ciblées en fonction du médicament ces
actions ciblées c'est l'interdiction
d'exporter pour les grossistes lorsque
les médicaments sont en France c'est une
distribution plus équitable sur le
territoire national via là aussi des
grossistes répartiteurs c'est une
prescription avec en officine
pharmaceutique la possibilité de donner
ce dont on a besoin voire même de
déconditionner les boîtes
travaillons aussi avec les sociétés
scientifiques pour pouvoir travailler
sur les alternatives puisqu'il n'est pas
envisageable bien entendu qu'on ne
puissions pas traiter l'ensemble des
Français et puis vous le savez France
2030 est le programme qui va nous
permettre de ramener en France les
productions ont tout du moins en Europe
pour faire de la France un produit un
produit un pays souverain en ce qui
concerne nos produits de santé pour cela
l'agence de l'innovation en santé a été
doté d'un budget plus que conséquent
comme vous le savez je vous remercie
ce ministre merci pour votre réponse
mais vous n'avez répondu que sur les
pénuries de médicaments vous n'avez pas
abordé la question des difficultés de se
fabrique en français le dernier
fabricant français de poche de perfusion
mais c'est révélateur la pandémie a déjà
rêvéler que la fusion de l'établissement
de préparation et de réponse aux
urgences sanitaires avec d'autres
agences pour former publique santé
publique France vous avez fait perdre à
l'époque toute capacité d'anticipation
d'une crise sanitaire vous avez voulu
une filière française de masque cela
risque de virer à la déroute vouloir
retrouver notre indépendance sanitaire
bien sûr évidemment nous y sommes
favorables c'est nécessaire et
indispensable notamment dans le cadre du
contexte international mais commençons
par ne pas perdre celle qui nous reste
c'est l'exemple de ce fabricant de poche
de perfusion mais c'est aussi l'exemple
de l'Établissement français du sang qui
aujourd'hui est en difficulté et qui
mérite toute l'attention du gouvernement
et si Monsieur ministre des hôpitaux ont
une dinde vis-à-vis de l'Établissement
français du sang je ne veux pas que
notre système de santé soit sacrifié sur
le thème de Bercy mais je vous vois
monsieur milite non je sais pas la tête
c'est la réalité ça a été confirmé ce
matin en audition par la commission des
affaires sociales les
pénuritables et toutes perte de notre
indépendance sanitaire monsieur le
Président et merci pour le temps serait
inacceptable merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Corinne
Ferret pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
aujourd'hui
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
pour répondre aux difficultés qu'il a
lui-même créé le gouvernement vient par
voie d'amendement au projet de loi de
finance 2023 d'instaurer un reste à
charge pour les salariés qui mobilisent
leur compte personnel de formation sur
le fond tout d'abord les Français qui
utiliseront leur CPF pour financer une
action de formation à nos compagnons
vers la VAE ou un bilan de compétence se
verront désormais impliquer une
franchise seules deux possibilités
d'exonération du ticket modérateur sont
prévues en somme on est très très loin
de ce que vous nous survons nous
survendu en 2018 avec la loi pour la
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel lorsque vous prétendiez je
cite vouloir libérer les salariés et
leur offrir plus de droits il faut le
dire c'en est fini du CPF dispositif
construit par les partenaires sociaux en
vue de permettre aux salariés d'établir
leur parcours professionnel votre mesure
est totalement injuste et viendra
éloigner encore plus de la formation les
salariés aux petites restauration et qui
sont souvent ceux qui ont le moins accès
les mêmes que vous voulez faire
travailler jusqu'à 65 ans et donc faire
payer pour se former et rester dans
l'emploi quant à la forme on ne décide
pas comme ça un week-end en pleine nuit
de remettre en question la formation
professionnelle ceci à coup de 49-3 sans
avoir échangé avec les partenaires
sociaux alors que ces derniers vous ont
remis très récemment des propositions
concrètes madame la ministre vous
engagez-vous enfin à les écouter en vue
de mettre en oeuvre des mesures juste de
régulation du CPF qui permettent de
concilier équilibre financier et
développement des compétences
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle un grand Jean merci
merci monsieur le président
médiateur madame la sénatrice de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit de revenir à
l'esprit du compte personnel de
formation d'abord en impliquant
davantage les bénéficiaires du compte
personnel de formation dans leur choix
de formation pour en faire un acte
réfléchi lié à un projet professionnel
cette disposition elle s'intègre dans
une logique globale je le disais tout à
l'heure elle est portée par le
gouvernement depuis plusieurs mois et
vise à corriger des dérives et des
fraudes relatives au système de
formation professionnelle des
dispositions dont le Parlement a déjà eu
à connaître et à débattre ont d'ailleurs
été adoptés pour cela nous nous sommes
également inspirés des propositions
faites dans votre propre rapport
concernant la soutenabilité Financière
de France compétences corrédigé avec vos
collègues Frédéric puissat et Martin
lévrier visant à mettre en place un
reste à charge au compte personnel de
formation pour ces raisons le
Gouvernement a déposé début novembre en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
un amendement visant à mettre en place
un mécanisme de régulation du compte de
formation pour attendre la fin des
négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux vous l'avez modifié au Sénat
pour poser directement le principe d'un
reste à charge et le Gouvernement a
souhaité proposer en seconde lecture un
amendement d'équilibre qui pose le
principe de participation du titulaire
mais aussi deux cas d'exonération pour
les demandeurs d'emploi et en cas
d'abondement par l'employeur dans les
formations qui sont proposées c'est donc
sur cette base aujourd'hui qui est
concertation vont s'engager avec les
partenaires sociaux les parlementaires
les acteurs de la formation pour
s'assurer que la participation de la
personne ne constituera pas une barrière
à la mobilisation des droits je vous
remercie
madame le ministre je ne voudrais pas
être désagréable mais je sais très bien
ce qu'il y a dans notre rapport c'est
notorial et vous ne pouvez pas dire ce
que vous venez de dire est déformer nos
écrits non nous n'avons pas évidemment
et décidément les mêmes valeurs car pour
moi le dialogue social c'est la
concertation c'est l'écoute c'est
l'échange et les recherches de solutions
avec les partenaires sociaux une fois de
plus vous avez fait les choses sans eux
alors qu'ils ne sont pas opposés à des
mesures permettant d'améliorer le
système actuel où est la justice sociale
dans ce que vous imposez nulle part vous
ne voulez rien contre construire vous
voulez obliger les salariés à tirer un
trait sur leurs droits sociaux et à
payer pour se former
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Isabelle Raymond pavéro pour le groupe
les républicains vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères depuis la mort de Maini aux
mains de la police des mœurs parce
qu'elles ne portait pas correctement son
voile le vendredi volte qu'il souffle
sur l'Iran ne faiblit pas et malgré la
férocité de la répression le cri femme
vie liberté résonne toujours plus fort
dans les rides du pays à ces trois mots
qui incarnent tout ce que la charia
tente d'étouffer depuis 40 ans le régime
des Molard réagit de la seule façon
qu'il connaisse par la brutalité la
terreur la reprise dépendaisons publics
vient rappeler au monde la barbarie à
laquelle le pouvoir iranien est prêt
pour se maintenir en place les
témoignages poignants recueillis au
Sénat lors d'une conférence organisant
soutien au club iranien ont montré à
quel point la violence faisait partie de
la nature profonde de ce régime malgré
tout ils sont toujours aussi nombreux
femmes et hommes à continu de braver la
peur à lever pour briser les carcans
imposés par la Révolution islamique à se
battre pour des valeurs qui sont aussi
les nôtres et dont nous nous prétendons
régulièrement les défenseurs la France
comme l'Europe reste dans une forme de
retrait de moins en moins compréhensible
au condamnation de principes et aux
messages de solidarité envers le peuple
iranien non ainsi que des
sanctions d'une surprenante faiblesse
madame la ministre concrètement quelles
initiatives le Gouvernement entend-il
prendre pour apporter un soutien en
soulèvement populaire iranien et pour
accentuer la pression internationale sur
les dignitaires du régime iranien
merci
pour vous répondre la parole que la
ministre de l'Europe des Affaires
étrangères madame Colonna
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vraiment pas Véro oui le
mouvement de protestation en Iran se
poursuit la répression violente c'est
poursuit également avec
500 morts dont des dizaines d'enfants on
a vu aussi avec
horreur des premières exécutions et
lundi lundi les ministres des Affaires
étrangères des 27 pays de l'Union
européenne ont demandé l'arrêt immédiat
de ses exécutions
l'exécution de manifestants ne peut
tenir lieu de réponse aux aspirations de
la jeunesse c'est une évidence madame la
Première ministre l'a rappelé la France
continue d'agir de manière résolue il
n'y a aucun retrait aucun recul madame
la sénatrice un nouveau train de
sanction européenne a été adopté lundi
qui cible notamment la police des mœurs
impliquée dans la répression des
manifestations ainsi que la radiotéision
iranienne il ne peut y avoir d'impunité
pour les responsables des violations des
droits fondamentaux et vous savez que
c'est la quatrième fois que les
Européens cet automne adoptent des
sanctions contre l'Iran il continueront
si nécessaire
ils ont aussi adopté lundi
pardonnez-moi de nouvelles conclusions
du Conseil très complètes sur l'Iran qui
constitue un cadre d'action d'une grande
fermeté par ailleurs face à la politique
qui est actuellement menée par la
République islamique d'Iran et nous
utiliserons pleinement ce cadre madame
le Premier ministre vous l'a indiqué
par ailleurs la France votre en faveur
du projet de texte portant exclusion de
l'Iran de la Commission des droits de
l'homme des droits de la femme dont font
partie
qui font partie des droits de l'homme
comme chacun le sait aux Nations Unies
je l'avais indiqué en audition à la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'Assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière et je vous le confirme la
France voter en faveur de ce texte
j'ajoute que celui-ci devrait être
adopté aujourd'hui même le loyer nous
continuons d'agir en soutenant
résolument cette pulsion de vie qui se
manifeste en Iran je remercie
merci Madame Raymond pavéro quelques
secondes
et face à un
tournant de voir la France l'Europe la
communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser il est temps qu'elle se montre
à la hauteur du courage des manifestants
iraniens notre pays fidèle à son
histoire et à ses valeurs doit être à
l'avant-garde c'est ce que nous ont
demandé au Sénat les résistants iraniens
merci
[Musique]
la parole est au président Laurent
Lafont pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci
monsieur le Président ce ministre de
l'Intérieur il y a quelques semaines
vous annonciez ici même au Sénat que des
festivals devront être annulés durant
l'été 2024 à cause des Jeux Olympiques
cette annonce a provoqué de nombreuses
réactions d'incompréhension la semaine
dernière avec plus d'une trentaine de
sénateurs et sénatrice membre de la
commission culture éducation et
communication du Sénat nous avons publié
dans le journal Le Monde une tribune
pour dire que le JO ne peuvent se faire
au détriment des nombreuses
manifestations sportives culturelles
festives qui ont lieu traditionnellement
partout en France madame la ministre de
la Culture a dans un interview pilier
aujourd'hui dans le journal Le Parisien
précisé que des solutions avaient été
trouvées pratiquement avec les tous les
grands festivals en tout cas ceux qui
recourent aux unités de force mobile
tant mieux néanmoins de nombreuses
questions demeure quid des grands
événements festifs qui ont lieu dans un
certain nombre de régions françaises
durant l'été je pense en particulier au
sud-ouest de la France avec des fêtes
comme celle de Bayonne ou de Dax quid de
la surveillance des plages qui jusqu'à
présent sont-elles assurés par des CRS
quid enfin des nombreux événements qui
pour se tenir ont besoin des de recourir
aux sociétés de sécurité privée on le
sait les JO vont massivement faire appel
à ces sociétés plus de 15
poste doivent être créés pour faire face
au seul besoin des Jeux Olympiques ces
sociétés pourront-elles couvrir à la
fois les besoins des événements en
province et se lier aux Jeux olympiques
et dans ces conditions monsieur le
ministre pourquoi ne pas compléter le
dispositif en recourant à l'armée
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur Gérald
Darmanin oui monsieur président
monsieur le Président Lafont les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris c'est une fois par
siècle
et les Jeux Olympiques à Paris avec une
cérémonie d'ouverture en dehors d'un
stade c'est une fois tous les 3000 ans
parce que personne ne l'a jamais
organisé en dehors d'un stade et je
pense que l'on peut constater ensemble
l'intérêt général qui a de réussir je
vous en ai particulièrement sensible je
le sais les Jeux olympiques de Paris et
les Jeux paralympiques qui s'étale
durant l'été 2024 je serai d'ailleurs
qu'en 2024 c'est aussi le 80e
anniversaire du débarquement de
Normandie c'est qu'il y a qu'au mois de
juin également il y aura énormément de
force des forces sécurité intérieure
pour protéger l'ensemble de ces grands
événements avec tous ces chefs d'État et
bien sûr cette grande familiature à
Paris ce que vous en proposez avec la
ministre de la Culture avec la ministre
des Sports en charge des Jeux Olympiques
ce n'est pas l'annulation des événements
c'est leur décalage notamment dans
l'OTAN et je crois que nous avons été en
partie entendu
par exemple le Tour de France qui ne va
pas arriver en 2024 à Paris et le 28
juillet mais à Nice le 21 juillet voilà
quelque chose qui nous paraît conforme à
l'intérêt général et conforme à la
volonté d'avoir évidemment un tour de
France en 2024 ou le festival des
Vieilles Charrues je peux aussi parler
du Festival d'Avignon et d'autres grands
festivals dont madame la ministre de la
Culture à l'occasion d'évoquer un
décalage de dates pour les Vieilles
Charrues elles se déroulant du 11 au 14
juillet au lieu du 18 au 21 juillet
comme quoi il est on est capable dans
notre pays de discuter en concertation
avec tous les acteurs du monde sportif
et culturel au niveau de festif en
général pour que ces événements se
tiennent mais dans des conditions où on
doit comprendre qu'il faut 45000
policiers et gendarmes pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris des années
d'ouverture jusqu'à sa fin en ce qui
concerne l'armée elle est déjà très
largement mobilisée si l'armée ne tenait
pas par exemple le site qui ferait
partir les bateaux sur la barge ce
serait 30 ufm que nous serons obligés
d'utiliser par les forces de l'ordre
l'armée c'est aussi ceux qui gardent la
politique aérienne se autorité de la
première ministre les lutte antidrone ou
contre l'arrivée de d'avion par exemple
au-dessus de nos événements mais l'armée
n'est pas fait pour les matières de
l'ordre voilà plus d'un siècle que nous
avons de spécialisé cela grâce à sa
forme de policiers et de gendarmes ce
n'est pas pour les confier à la va-vite
il faut conclure à des militaires on
aura l'occasion d'en parler la sécurité
privée on en fait le ministre de du
travail un certain nombre de démarches
très positif qui nous permet d'être
confiant dans la présence de la sécurité
privée partout sur le territoire
national que le président Lafont
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur ministre pour ces
éléments de réponse
n'avons pas forcément compris la façon
dont la question des festivals avait été
abordée jusqu'à présent vous faites une
annonce et quelques semaines après nous
annonce que finalement les solutions
étaient trouvées dont un acte étant
mieux mais pour éviter que ces solutions
ne se reproduisent nous souhaiterions
notamment que au niveau des territoires
et avec les élus locaux nous fassiez un
inventaire précis des manifestations et
que vous abordiez concrètement quelles
solutions peuvent être trouvées dans un
contexte on le sait et vous l'avez
rappelé qui est exceptionnel avec les
difficultés que peuvent engendrer
l'organisation d'une manifestations
aussi importante que celle des JO
néanmoins le dialogue avec les élus
locaux sur ce point nous sommes
extrêmement importants
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Béatrice Gosselin pour le groupe les
républicain
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mieux chez moi mieux pour ma
planète voici le slogan qui présente ma
prime rénoble aide aux financement des
travaux de rénovation énergétique
calculez en fonction des revenus et du
gain écologiques des travaux travaux
principalement d'isodation et de
chauffage qui doivent être effectuées
par des entreprises labellisées RGE
lorsque votre logement est mal isolé ou
équipé d'un mode de chauffage dont le
coût augmente de façon exponentielle
vous êtes évidemment intéressé par ce
dispositif quand vous cliquez sur le
site vous lisez une aide accessible à
tous propriétaires ou copropriétaires
occupant ou bailleurs qui s'adapte à la
situation de chacun et favorise des
rénovations ambitieuses cela paraît
simple et attractif si dans donc dans de
nombreux cas pardon les démarches
aboutissent et les primes sont versées
dans un délai raisonnable certains
dossiers connaissent des difficultés
importantes et les aident arrivent
tardivement jusqu'à 10 mois après les
travaux
numéro national 08 injoignable
difficulté pour accéder à l'interface
dossier accepté dans un premier temps
puis refuser pour l'usager c'est 15
jours maximum pour compléter ou corriger
un dossier mais des semaines sans
réponse de la part du service ma prime
rénov ainsi de nombreuses personnes se
trouvent en difficulté financière quand
les travaux sont à payer et que l'aide
notifié par l'État se fait attendre
c'est aussi le cas de d'entreprises
d'artisans RGE qui remplissent les
dossiers pour leurs clients et qui
attendent longtemps les paiements des
primes fragilisant ainsi leur trésorerie
même des référents préfecture ont des
difficultés à avoir des retours des
dossiers en souffrance alors monsieur le
ministre que comptez-vous faire pour
améliorer ce dispositif et ne pas mettre
particulier et entreprises en difficulté
pour vous répondre la parole à Olivier
Klein mélise délégué en charge de la
ville et du logement chez le ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Gosselin vous avez raison il
existe un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnement mais je crois d'abord
qu'il ne doivent pas masquer les 1,5
millions de chantier qui ont été
réalisés dans le cadre de ma prime
rénove 1,5 millions de chantiers qui ont
été en particulier aidé 80% de ménage
modestes et quand on interroge les
ménages 66% des ménages qui ont fait ces
travaux n'auraient pas fait ces travaux
sans ma prime rénove néanmoins oui des
difficultés existent un certain nombre
d'irègues d'irrégularités voire de
fraude ont été constatés et ça nous a
obligé dans la volonté du gouvernement
d'être très attentif à assez fraude de
prendre un peu plus de temps sur
l'évaluation des dossiers mais je peux
vous assurer que tous les services de la
NAS sont extrêmement mobilisés pour
régler ces différentes difficultés
prendre des contacts individuels avec
les familles dans lesquelles les
dossiers prennent trop de temps j'étais
avant-hier je crois en rendez-vous avec
la faire des droits et nous avons évoqué
un certain nombre de cas qui lui avait
été remontés nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied pour régler ses problèmes
c'est tout le sens de ce grand service
public qui est France rénov que nous
allons faire progresser que nous allons
faire améliorer en termes de performance
parce que oui un certain nombre de
nombreux travaux ont déjà été réalisés
mais il faut aller plus loin dans la
performance et dans des travaux globaux
aller plus loin dans les travaux dans
les copropriétés dans l'habitat
collectif parce que c'est oui vous avez
raison comme c'est indiqué sur le site
le chantier du siècle et je peux vous
assurer de la détermination de mon
ministère du gouvernement et de la
première ministre sur ce dossier merci
Madame Gosselin
j'entends bien monsieur le ministre mais
il est vrai que certains entreprises
rencontrent des difficultés de
trésorerie quand elles ont 15 20 000
euros pour des petites entreprises c'est
beaucoup et je pense que Lana qui est
l'interlocuteur pourrait entrer dans le
dispositif du bouquet de français
service qui permettrait à des habitants
de pouvoir avoir une réponse rapide et
efficace merci merci
[Applaudissements]
non monsieur le ministre je suis désolé
on ne fait pas de commentaires sur le
commentaire ici alors je donne la parole
maintenant à notre collègue Jean-Jacques
le sac pour le gros socialiste
écologiste la République
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la transition
écologique et la cohésion des
territoires et porte la mise en œuvre de
0 artificialisation nette à l'horizon
2050 et sur la réduction de moitié d'ici
à 2030 du rythme de consommation des
espaces naturels agricoles et forestiers
sinon de contestons pas les objectifs de
sobriété foncières et de préservation
environnementale de cette réforme
structurante pour nos territoires des
points de crispation demeure portant la
fois sur la méthode employée largement
descendante et sur le fond des
dispositifs cette première étape d'usine
s'est opérée dans la plus grande
confusion générant incompréhension et
inquiétude chez beaucoup d'élus le Sénat
est à nouveau saisi de cette
problématique en lançant une mission
conjointe de contrôle la proposition de
loi issus de ces travaux doit permettre
une évolution rapide du cadre juridique
du zan et dans son déploiement de temps
de vers davantage de discernement de
pragmatisme et de bon sens nous
attendons ainsi le gouvernement des
engagements clairs sur la temporalité
avec la révision du calendrier des
modifications des documents de
planification sur la gouvernance une
grande partie des élus demeure écartées
des négociations ce qui est inadmissible
je rappelle que le nombre départements
reste totalement ou partiellement
dépourvu de Scott chez Mad cohérence
territoriale d'où l'absent en délu
siégeant à la Conférence régionale des
stradettes il faut renforcer la
concertation entre région Scott et bloc
communale en dotant le zan d'une
gouvernance plurielle partagée et
décentralisée sur la différenciation en
garantissant la prise en compte des
particularités du monde rural et les
spécificités territoriales effort
passées projet développement local
spécificités des zones littorales et de
montagne pour préserver le droit à
construire des communes rurales ne
faut-il pas laisser la libre
appréciation de leurs élus une surface
minimale garantie par le Scott enfin la
logique d'usage étant celle d'une
densification de que pensez-vous de
l'opportunité de lancer un programme
national et complémentaire de
réhabilitation du bâti ancien en centre
bourg pour vous répondre la parole
d'État monsieur Christophe Buchs mini
c'est la transition du écologique de la
cohésion des territoires c'est le
ministre
monsieur président mesdames
messenatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Lauzac je pense
qu'entre la première question au
gouvernement à laquelle j'ai eu
l'honneur de répondre dans cette
hémicycle sur le zan au mois de juillet
et aujourd'hui je dois être rendu à
presque une trentaine d'heures
d'échanges avec la chambre haute sur le
sujet et la dernière en date à
l'invitation de la présidente Valérie
léthard juste avant que la présentation
de la PPL est lieu aujourd'hui
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
plusieurs groupes nous avons même
échangé ensemble il y a peu de temps sur
le sujet j'ai rencontré les associations
d'élus et j'attends dans les milles qui
viennent la fumée blanche du texte que
le Sénat va proposer pour faire en sorte
d'amander le dispositif dans l'esprit
d'ouverture que le gouvernement a
indiqué depuis le début du mois d'août
quand il a suspendu la mise en oeuvre
des décrets de la fin du mois d'avril je
vous rappelle les étapes qui sont calées
pour ceux qui relèvent du pouvoir
réglementaire la réécriture des décrets
est prévue pour le début de l'année
prochaine nous avons fait travailler les
agents d'urbanisme et les associations
de maires pour déterminer la granularité
la manière d'aller écrire ce qui relève
des espaces naturels et agricoles la
première ministre a eu des mots
extrêmement clairs en clôture du Salon
des mers à la fois sur les grands
projets d'envergure national et sur la
garantie rurale ce qui nous importe
c'est d'abord de rappeler et je ne doute
pas compte tenu de vos propos que tous
nous sommes convaincus de la nécessité
de la sobriété foncière
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à rythme
artificialisation qui bouge nos dates
préatiques qui crée des îlots de chaleur
et qui nous empêche demain de préserver
des espaces agricoles dont nous avons
besoin y compris pour notre souveraineté
alimentaire dans le même temps il nous
faut mieux associer les élus parce que
dans la façon dont le texte a été rédigé
dans les mises en oeuvre qui sont
envisagées il suscite aujourd'hui des
inquiétudes certaines sont fondées
d'autres ne le sont pas le meilleur
exemple c'est que des milliers de
communes sont déjà en situation de 0
artificialisation nette sans le savoir
ou qu'elle soit en zone inondable ou
qu'elle soit cernées par des AOC ou
qu'elle soit en RNU donc je me réjouis
du fait qu'on aura très vite l'occasion
de débattre non plus du principe mais
des modalités
la parole est à notre collègue marc
Laménie pour le groupe les républicains
merci
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre délégué
changer des transports et concernant le
volet ferroviaire et l'ensemble aussi
des personnels le 14 novembre dernier
vers 19h dans les Ardennes Donchery
commune d'un peu plus de 2000 habitants
situés sur la ligne SNCF
Charleville-Mézières Sedan un père de
famille et sa fille ont été tués happées
par un train de marchandises en
descendant d'un TER qui dessert cette
gare ce drame qui a suscité beaucoup
d'émotions dans ce boursontre et dans
les Ardennes mais en évidence les
problèmes de sécurité cette gare située
sur l'axe calebal le double voie
électrifié n'est pas équipé de passage
souterrains demande formulée de longue
date par le maire et ses collègues ni de
passage supérieur seul des pictogrammes
indique la présence d'un train croiseur
pour les voyageurs à noter que cette
gare est utilisée aussi par des
travailleurs qui font partie d'une
section
sur l'ensemble du réseau national plus
de 900 traversées de voies
pour piétons existent monsieur le
ministre quelle mesure on visait vous
pour le sécurité des usagers et surtout
en parlant de moyens humains renforcés
les moyens humains de présence dans les
gars TER notamment et présence
indispensable des contrôleurs parce que
là malheureusement il y avait pas de
contrôleurs ainsi que dans les gars je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est communiste déléguée charger
les transports
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur à la mini je vais d'abord
m'associer à l'émotion que vous avez
relayée dans l'hémicycle après le drame
de Donchery et il y a quelques jours qui
a emporté la mort de deux personnes et
je tiens à vous indiquer que même si
nous n'avons pas encore l'ensemble des
éléments sur les causes et conditions de
ce drame le bureau enquête analyse dans
sa section chargée de transport
terrestre a ouvert à ma demande une
enquête et tous les éléments qui ont
évidemment communiqués le plus
rapidement possible après l'ensemble des
investigations nécessaires cela pose la
question d'un certain nombre
d'aménagement d'informations de
formation qui doivent être renforcés au
sein de la SNCF notamment dans des
petites gares ou des haltes comme
c'était le cas en l'espèce et j'ai
demandé en effet au président de la SNCF
au PDG de SNCF voyageurs de prévoir un
ensemble d'actions renforcées au-delà de
ce qui a déjà été engagé depuis
maintenant trois ans sur la
signalisation sur l'information en gare
sur la formation des conducteurs sur les
points de danger particulier en termes
de visibilité ou de difficultés de je
suis prêt à regarder le dossier de longs
chéris spécifiquement avec vous mais
malheureusement c'est quelques centaines
de lieux qui sont concernés encore en
France aujourd'hui nous avons fait un
travail engagé par Elisabeth Borre
lorsqu'elle était Ministre chargé les
transports pour aménager un certain
nombre de passager à niveau mais la
question a notamment dans les halles de
ferroviaires d'un certain nombre
d'aménagements de formation et de la
formation doivent être renforcés je suis
prêt à y travailler avec le Sénat avec
vous en particulier je connais votre
engagement au-delà de ce drame sur la
question ferroviaire je me tiens donc à
votre disposition
Monsieur Le Mesnil
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci pour ces informations et
surtout une solidarité puisque je crois
que c'est réellement important bon c'est
vrai que le cheval de bataille de
beaucoup d'eau de nos collègues
également je partage sur tous les bancs
c'est aussi les moyens humains parce que
les moyens humains sont réellement
indispensables c'est vu un contrôleur je
pense que ce drame aurait été évité j'ai
aussi en mémoire deux drames qui ont été
évités grâce aussi au personnel et au
conducteur ben un train qui déraille à
cause d'un convoi exceptionnel et puis
un TER qui avait heurté aussi quelques
années un convoi exceptionnel donc merci
sincèrement puis c'est surtout c'est un
combat collectif merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
et nous pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
concerne les ZFE zone un faible émission
une idée séduisante une idée européenne
séduisante mais dans l'application est
particulièrement complexe et j'y vois
une incohérence environnementale une
injustice sociale une fracture
territoriale voire générationnelle et un
choix industriel incertain une
incohérence environnementale faire peser
sur le sol citoyen automobiliste la
responsabilité du réchauffement
climatique ou des particules dans les
villes m'apparaît excessif il faudra pas
longtemps avant qu'on dise que le
responsable du réchauffement climatique
c'est la mobylette de l'ouvrier la
justice sociale et bien ce sont les plus
modestes qui sont impactés il suffit
d'aller dans les quartiers pour
constater que vous voyez des véhicules
dans les quartiers de gens modeste des
véhicules d'alvinet 5 des vignettes 4
une fracture territoriale voire des
générationnelle et bien ce sont les
habitants des campagnes ceux de la
ruralité du périurbain ainsi un couple
de retraités qui a une clio diesel
depuis plusieurs années ne peut plus
aller voir ses enfants en ville et enfin
un choix industriel incertain
l'industrie automobile européenne n'est
pas prête à cette mutation vers le
véhicule électrique aussi rapidement il
y a 30% de de cette industrie qui est
qui est en danger et donc ma question
concerne votre vision des aides quelle
application et quelles conséquences sur
Vinci pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre délégué chargé les
transports monsieur Clément Beaud nous
avait la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Hainaut permettez-moi de
revenir d'un mot rapide sur l'objectif
des zones affaiblissement parce qu'elles
ne sont pas en soi une volonté
évidemment d'exclure de priver d'excès
au centre urbain toute une partie de la
population elles viennent d'une
nécessité constater et votée par le
Parlement dans deux textes législatifs
il y a quelques années la loi
d'orientation des mobilités la loi
climat résilience qui vise à mettre en
place progressivement j'insiste sur ce
point dans 43 métropoles françaises de
plus de 150 000 habitants des zones en
laissant une très grande flexibilité aux
collectivités locales concernent c'est
un outil entre les mains des
collectivités locales concernées qui
doit être adaptée à la réalité de
chacune de ces métropoles et ses
agglomérations le calendrier n'est pas
prédéfini sauf pour les métropoles qui
sont en dépassement de normes de qualité
de l'air nous faisons ça précisément
pour réduire les impacts sur les
qualités sur la qualité de l'air et pour
améliorer et pour éviter les plus le
45000 morts chaque année constaté à
cette pollution c'est cela l'objectif en
laissant cette règle la possibilité
cette flexibilité s'étend aussi au type
de modalités de circulation d'accès qui
sont des qui sont décidés pardon par
chacune de ces collectivités avec une
grande différenciation qui sera précisée
et définie par chacune des métropoles le
rôle de l'État c'est d'être en
accompagnement pour que précisément les
risques que vous identifiez à juste
titre socio générationnel territoriaux
ne se réalise pas et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons déployé
progressivement en lien avec les
métropoles les aides pour que la mise en
place progressive des et des feux se
fasse le mieux possible les ailes c'est
notamment l'acquisition de véhicules le
bonus écologique la prime à la
conversion nous avons décidé dans le
projet de loi de finances pour 2023
soumis au scénar et à l'Assemblée
d'augmenter à 7000 euros le bonus pour
les ménages les plus modestes nous avons
aussi c'était une idée de plusieurs
sénatrices et sénateurs d'expérimenter
une un prêt à taux zéro dans deux zones
affaiblission et de métropoles
aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts à
l'étendre et en regardait les modalités
avec vous dans les prochains mois donc
nous devrons évidemment renforcer encore
nos accomp travailler avec les
métropoles mais je le dis la flexibilité
du dispositif est entre les mains des
collectivités pour que ça se passe le
mieux possible dans le calendrier le
plus adapté possible
je suis Hainaut oui merci monsieur le
ministre je ne doute pas évidemment de
votre bonne foi de votre bonne volonté
mais ceci dit trois observations il
faudra pas longtemps avant que les aides
et feux deviennent des zones à forte
exclusion
je pense aussi que il y a dans cette
écologie culpabilisante il y a une
obsession de la comme plutôt qu'un souci
du bien public et puis aussi un mépris
social c'est quand même la France des
clopes et du diesel qu'on regarde encore
de haut et il y a dans tout ça un germe
de gilets jaunes je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
j'ai le plaisir de saluer la présence de
la tribune d'honneur une délégation de
si parlementaire de la Chambre des
conseillers du Royaume du Maroc présidée
par le docteur Mohamed Didou président
du groupe d'amitié
[Applaudissements]
du groupe d'amitié Maroc France à la
Chambre des conseillers notre collègue
Christian Cambon président du groupe
d'amitié est présent à leur côté lors de
l'entretien que nous avons eu en fin de
matinée nous avons évoqué les
principales étapes de leur séjour ici à
Paris et en Normandie qui leur
permettront de s'entretenir avec le
ministre Olivier belge réveil d'ailleurs
d'un déplacement au Maroc madame la
ministre de Madame la Ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères il
devrait ensuite découvrir les travaux de
recherche et développement menés par EDF
en matière nucléaire et d'énergie
renouvelable et visiter les chantiers
naval à Cherbourg cet accueil témoigne
de la relation privilégiée qui nous lie
au Royaume du Maroc et à sa chambre des
conseillers et de notre attachement et
d'amitié ancienne qui dans cette
dimension parlementaire s'exprime avec
une force particulière même lorsque
quelques tensions a pu apparaître dans
la situation bilatérale nous avons su
garder intact cette capacité d'écouter
de dialogue qui est la marque des
amitiés sincères le jumelage en cours
entre nous assemblées et aussi le Sénat
italien le dynamisme des relations entre
le groupe d'amitié respectifs me semble
une parfaite illustration madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
permettez-moi de souhaiter à nos amis
membres de la Chambre des conseillers du
Maroc la plus cordiale bienvenue au
Sénat de la République française
où est mon texte
nous en avons terminé mes chers
collègues avec les questions au
Gouvernement
nous nous retrouverons pour les
questions gouvernement début d'année
avec bonheur ce qui me permet de
souhaiter à chacune et à chacun
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année à
remercier les collègues les ministres
mais ça n'est pas terminé puisque
16h35 nous reprenons pour l'examen d'une
Commission Mixte Paritaire la séance est
donc suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette toute dernière séance
des questions d'actualité le
gouvernement de l'année 2022 ici au
Sénat parmi les temps forts que l'on a
retenu de cette séance que vous avez
suivi en intégralité en direct sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat il y a eu ces
échanges autour de la souveraineté
sanitaire la charge est venue des LR
avec la sénatrice Corinne Imbert
pharmacienne de profession elle a refait
la liste inquiétante on peut le dire un
des médicaments dont les stocks
s'amenuisent le paracétamol
l'amoxicilline mais aussi elle nous l'a
appris les poches de perfusion pour des
hôpitaux ce qui pourrait venir à manquer
elle a dit toutes ces pénuries sont
insupportables et toutes pertes de notre
souveraineté sanitaire n'est plus
acceptable écoutez alors la réponse du
ministre de la Santé François Brune qui
a semblé minimisé la crise notre système
de surveillance qui est porté par
l'Agence nationale du système de
sécurité pardon du médicament nous
permet de choses nous permet déjà d'être
alerté très tôt puisque les alertes
arrivent lorsque nos stocks diminuent en
dessous de 1 pour la plupart des
produits donc ça veut pas dire que nous
n'en avons plus mais en tout cas des
stocks sont extrêmement bas et elle nous
permet aussi d'identifier les causes ces
causes nous permettant d'avoir des
actions ciblées en fonction du
médicament alors Caroline Imbert n'a pas
du tout été satisfaite de cette réponse
et de se semblant de satisfait site que
semble s'octroyer le ministre de la
Santé elle lui a répliqué après et le
ministre faisait des noms de la tête et
elle insistait à écouter un extrait
je ne veux pas que notre système de
santé soit sacrifié sur le thème de
Bercy mais si je vous vois monsieur
milite non je sais pas la tête c'est la
réalité ça a été confirmé ce matin en
audition par la commission des affaires
sociales les pénuries sont
insupportables et toute perte de notre
indépendance sanitaire monsieur le
Président et merci pour le temps serait
inacceptable voilà pour cet échange qui
est parmi les temps forts de la séance
cette semaine Tam merci merci beaucoup
Quentin pour se décryptage de cette
dernière séance de questions au
gouvernement de 2022 tout de suite le
débrief on va commencer par faire un
tour sale des conférences et rejoindre
Alexandre Poussard qui se trouve avec le
ministre chargé de la ville et du
logement il s'agit d'Olivier Klein votre
micro et oui Olivier Klein on va on va
parler de ce que prévoit le gouvernement
cette période de grand froid avec des
associations d'aide au logement qui
lancent l'air notamment sur des
plateformes